ever since putin invaded ukraine the
world has bombarded russia with
sanctions restrictions and limitations
in terms of transportation boeing airbus
ford mercedes toyota and volkswagen have
all suspended exports and or stopped
operations in russia in terms of tech
apple has halted all product sales in
russia google has demonetized russian
state media and facebook and tick tock
have blocked russian state media
altogether in europe in terms of energy
exxon shell bpa and ecuador have
announced that they will be canceling
investments in russia and or leaving
russia completely in terms of logistics
ups and fedex have halted shipments to
russia and ukraine in terms of finances
several russian banks have been barred
from the swift system and switzerland
has frozen russian assets and that
doesn't even include the countrywide
bans on bonds airspace restrictions and
limitations on russian banks and the
oligarchs
considering all this there's no question
that once everything is said and done in
ukraine russia is screwed economically
in fact in just the past one month the
usda rupal exchange rate has exploded
from 75 rupees per dollar to over 120
rupees per dollar
this means that the russian ruble has
lost nearly 40 of its value against the
dollar
meanwhile the russian stock market
crashed 33 the day after the invasion
even with the russian central bank
closing the stock market and at the time
of making this video russia has refused
to reopen the market in fear of even
greater losses so how screwed really is
the russian economy
[Music]
we hear all this news about sanctions
and restrictions on russia but what does
this really do to the economy well from
a consumer's perspective it seems like
you just can't travel as much abroad and
you can't buy certain foreign goods but
the true consequences are much more deep
rooted and painful with the first being
uncontrollable inflation like any other
product on the market the russian ruble
is subject to supply and demand
constraints
and the value of the ruble in relation
to other currencies is dependent on how
many people want the ruble versus the
other currency when a country is
exporting a bunch of goods like russia a
lot of countries and companies will need
the ruble to purchase russian goods but
when basically every russian good is
blocked from being imported the demand
for the ruble falls off a cliff in the
meantime russians are still dependent on
a lot of foreign goods including basics
like food clothing and medicine and in
order to obtain these essentials
russians must give up rubles in exchange
for dollars euros or whatever the case
may be russia has tried to soften this
demand by limiting imports into the
country but with how interconnected the
global economy is today it's nearly
impossible to break away and to become
independent this means that the supply
of rubles from russians hasn't really
changed all that much while the demand
for the ruble from foreigners has
evaporated and basic economics will tell
you that this screws over the ruble and
that's why it has dropped nearly 40 in
the past few weeks but uncontrollable
inflation is not even that bad when you
consider that the entire financial
system is in danger of collapsing you
see it not only do sanctions limit the
demand for rubles but it makes it
extremely difficult to access ruble that
are stored in foreign countries ever
since 2014 russia's central bank has
been building up massive positions in
foreign currencies it's estimated that
they hold 630 billion dollars in foreign
currencies this was a strategic move to
protect russia against inflation but
this has kind of backfired the 630
billion dollars worth of foreign
currency is worth significantly more
than if they had just held the money in
rubles but given all these sanctions
they don't actually have access to this
money
not only does this make it more
difficult for russia to fund their
activities but more importantly they're
now facing a massive liquidity problem
and given that this is public knowledge
russian banks are scrambling to prevent
a bank run one of these countermeasures
was raising interest rates from 9.5
percent to 20
this is truly quite amusing over here in
the us the stock market is throwing a
tantrum because powell might increase
interest rates by half a percent after
months of heads up but russia literally
raised interest rates by 10 and a half
percent overnight russia is hoping that
20 interest rates will convince russians
to keep their money in the bank and that
they can avoid a bank run but the
situation is still extremely fragile and
that one big catalyst could destroy the
russian financial system
even if russia is able to avoid a
full-on financial collapse the next
several years will still be quite
painful anyway you see it when a bunch
of everyday goods rise in price by 40
people will need to spend significantly
more money on living expenses for many
everyday russians this means withdrawing
from savings and or going broke in the
meantime businesses will have to pay
significantly more for their goods which
means that they'll have to raise prices
on their products just to stay afloat
but by raising prices a lot of their
customers would no longer be able to
afford these goods which means that
they'll get less business and may end up
going bankrupt anyway businesses that do
survive will have to pay their employees
significantly higher salaries which
means that they'll probably be more
conservative when it comes to hiring and
they might even let go of a few
employees not only does this
dramatically increase the workload for
the remaining employees but this will
dramatically increase unemployment and
when people are unemployed consumers as
a whole will spend less money which
means even less revenue for businesses
which could lead to another round of
layoffs and then the cycle starts all
over again also what about the well-off
russians i'm not talking about
billionaire oligarchs but the everyday
millionaires that worked saved and
invested for 40 50 years just to attain
some level of financial freedom
at this rate these individuals will have
to return to work very soon something
else to consider is that the inflation
that russia has seen so far could just
be the beginning about 25 years ago in
1998 russia experienced a similar
financial fallout due to a different set
of circumstances things got so bad that
russia ended up defaulting on domestic
debt which led to the rupaul jumping off
a cliff before the crisis you could get
one us dollar using five to six rubles
but after the crisis you needed 30 rupos
to just get a single dollar this means
that by the time things stabilized the
ruble had lost 80 to 90 percent of its
value if we see something similar right
now each us dollar could be equivalent
to 400 rupees by the end of this crisis
and that's if things end up stabilizing
the 1998 financial crisis was not a
result of the world powers trying to
punish russia it was due to
unsustainable economic and financial
practices similar to the 2008 financial
recession so for the most part no one
was trying to intentionally screw over
russia but the same cannot be said about
the current situation
so if worse comes to worst it's possible
that russia enters hyperinflation on the
scale of venezuela zimbabwe and germany
after world war one and at that point
there's really nothing left to do but
start over so even if the russian
economy doesn't implode due to sanctions
it's possible that the economy bleeds
out due to hyperinflation
the collateral damage of a financial
crisis and inflation alone is horrendous
but we haven't even discussed the future
of the russian stock market and its
collateral damage at the time of making
this video russia is yet to reopen the
stock market but a lot of russian stocks
are available on different exchanges
like the london stock exchange and so
far they have lost 33 percent of their
value which correlates to a 200 billion
loss in market cap that makes this crash
the fifth worst crash in stock market
history and that's with the london
exchange suspending russian stocks if
london hadn't suspended these stocks
it's quite possible that these stocks
would be down over 50 by now for a lot
of you guys it might be confusing as to
how the stock market affects the average
russian given that the average russian
likely doesn't own many stocks well even
though the average russian may not incur
drag losses on stockholdings they will
likely face several indirect
consequences to understand this we have
to first take a look at why the stock
market is even crashing in the first
place the answer in this case is obvious
with all these sanctions and
restrictions it's unlikely that most
russian companies will be able to pull
in the revenue and profits that they
used to many of these companies will no
longer be profitable and will be headed
towards bankruptcy and given the low
investor trust in russia it's gonna be
nearly impossible for these companies to
raise money by selling shares this
leaves them with only two options either
they can fight for profitability until
they go bankrupt at which point they'll
have to shut down operations and lay off
all their employees or they'll likely
have to get a bailout from the
government which would simply increase
the odds of hyperinflation neither of
these options is particularly favorable
to the average person either they lose
their job or they lose their savings and
what about retirees
most retirees in russia depend on
various pension and retirement plans and
these plans have investments in the
stock market with the stock market
having in value and their foreign assets
being frozen it's gonna be a lot harder
for these funds to pay out their
millions of beneficiaries these funds
may be forced to default or borrow money
to pay out their beneficiaries and given
that russian interest rates are as high
as credit cards right now you definitely
don't want to be borrowing money clearly
even though the average russian may not
directly have stock holdings a stock
market crash would be pretty painful for
them as well
at the end of the day the west doesn't
agree with putin's invasion of ukraine
and this has caused them to take severe
action 100 years ago the west may have
entered into a war against russia or
entered into an arms race against russia
but today governments are trying to
address the situation diplomatically
instead of fighting a deadly war or
building up weapons of mass destruction
the west is trying to get russia to back
off by threatening their economy and
with the biggest countries and companies
on board it seems to be pretty effective
in causing economic damage however it's
unclear if this will actually lead to
russia backing down here's the thing
even if they did back down putin has
permanently burned a lot of bridges by
deciding to invade so it's unlikely that
their economy will just return to normal
if they leave ukraine considering this
if the russian economy is screwed either
way why not make a statement on your way
out and it looks like that's what putin
has chosen to do
looking forward it's unlikely that the
russian economy will completely collapse
or enter hyperinflation though those do
have non-negligible probabilities the
more likely scenario is that russia
falls down another tier amongst world
powers economically with the everyday
russian bearing most of the fallout
while that's quite a shame hopefully all
these efforts make it substantially
harder for putin to invade yet another
country but only time will tell do you
guys think the russian economy is crude
comment that down below
also drop a like if you feel bad for the
everyday russian and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch your videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]
you